[Music]
what a week this has been for Roseanne
Barr blasted for her racist tweet and
then for hit show canceled yeah keV even
her mental health has been called into
question and there is new fallout
tonight Roseanne Barr is revealing that
she quote Bank ABC executives not to
cancel her show tweeting I told them I
was willing to do anything on Wednesday
she criticized cast mate Sara Gilbert
and Michael Fishman for condemning her
racist tweet yesterday she wrote I
forgive you both love you both
just wish you could have called me
personally to talk rather than do it in
a public arena but Roseanne says that
the saddest part of the controversy
involves nine year-old Jaden Rae who
played her granddaughter Roseanne writes
am so ashamed of myself that she would
ever think I do not love her because she
is african-american back in april jaden
told us roseanne was an inspiration i'm
so happy the rest of my life i think you
have a good start i love this meanwhile
there's another twist today the 65 year
old comedian tried to explain herself by
posting a series of children's videos
she made back in 2006 including this
animation that she captioned by real
views on all races and people
she dedicated this Bob Marley cover to
quote everyone who is suffering today
[Music]
and Roseanne apparently backed out of a
scheduled podcast interview today with
comedian Joe Rogan he says she was not
doing well and doesn't want to travel
yesterday on the Joe Rogan experience he
shared details of a phone conversation
they had earlier this week she told me
that she was taking ambien and that she
was drunk in my world Day weekend and
she tweeted a bunch of stupid she's out
of fun and she said you know in her
words I need to adjust my meds you know
I'm not thinking straight and she was
talking about how exhausted she got
doing that television show and she got
bronchitis and she was overworked I
don't think she's lying to me I don't
think she's racist
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]